alright guys today we're gonna talk
about cortisol and the quality of sleep
that you get now cortisol actually is on
a circadian rhythm okay so you have
these waves of hormones so if we take a
look at this is the cortisol way 8:00 in
the morning is when you have the highest
cortisol levels supposedly in theory
right and then starts to decrease
through the day 12:00 noon for eight
starts coming down and then eight pm
over here and then it hits its lowest
between 12 and like two o'clock in the
middle of the night 12 midnight and 2
a.m. okay this is when we're supposed to
be sleeping in deep sleep so that's the
normal pattern that you're supposed to
go through if these circadian waves are
out of whack and you could have high
cortisol in the middle of the night and
low cortisol in the morning okay and so
that's a situation where you just in the
morning is like that's your best sleep
so just when the alarm clock goes off
that's when you really want to go to
sleep yet at two o'clock in the morning
or 12 you're like wide awake like ready
to go that's because your circadian
waves are off and these circadian waves
are influenced by a lot of different
things one is other hormone like
neurotransmitters like serotonin or
melatonin which is made by the pineal
gland in the brain
now the pineal is synced up with this
tiny little clock in your hypothalamus
in your brain
it's called the super cheese Matic
Nikolai not that you need to know that
but if you're ever on Trivial Pursuit
and that comes up now you know so this
gland that triggers melatonin which
helps you go to sleep is triggered by
darkness okay so no lights so ideally
before you go to bed you should have
lower lights right you shouldn't have
bright lights in your eyes because it
goes right to the eyes and then it
triggers these this cascade of hormones
and then in the morning when you wake up
you're supposed to have lights that
wakes you up the Sun comes up the light
wakes you up but because we're in rooms
that are lighted all day long
until we go to sleep you can throw
things off as well and the ideal time to
go to bed would be roughly 10:30 ish you
know you can go a little bit early a
little bit later now you also have other
waves going on that are not directly
related to cortisol but you like your
sleep waves you go through for 90
minutes sleep cycles okay and you go
from a superficial sleep which is the
REM sleep to the deeper sleep which is
called the Delta there's actually four
levels there and it's all synced with
the amount of light and darkness that
your eye is exposed to so I personally
go to bed at around 10:30 and let's see
11:30 12 31 32 33 34 35 30 so I'll get
it I'll wake up about five o'clock so
I'll get six and a half hours and I am
good with that I don't really need
anything else back in the morning at at
five o'clock in the morning I can't
sleep in I am totally awake and I'm
ready to go now I may take a little nap
right here a power nap I can actually
just go out within a minute and just you
know ten minutes later wake up feeling
refreshed and I might maybe run around
here or here take that little power nap
but I found that when you do for a min
and fasting the need for sleep goes down
you don't need as much sleep so there
are certain things that can really mess
up your cortisol okay physical stress
trauma surgeries emotional stress losses
so chronic sustained stress or a long
period of time can really mess up
cortisol too much caffeine in college I
drank pots of coffee okay to stay awake
eventually madrina start going downhill
we have sugar that can create all sorts
of blood sugar problems insulin
resistance and what happens to if you
have a blood sugar problem is that when
you go to bed at night you might wake up
because of a hypoglycemic reaction when
the blood sugars go down okay because in
this situation when you have blood sugar
issues you can't go for a long period of
time without eating so normally you're
eating like every hour and a half from
every two hours because you're always
hungry or snacking but when you go to
bed let's say you're going about at
10:30 you're not gonna potentially eat
for another of seven hours right well
what happens with blood sugar problems
as you end up with hypoglycemia in the
middle of the night and you have counter
hormones that counter this drop in blood
sugar they're called counter regulating
hormones the big one is adrenaline so
adrenaline releases sugar from stored
sugar and it actually even can help you
make new sugar and we get this
adrenaline effect which is basically dis
countering the low blood sugar and it
just pumps you right out of that deep
sleep so this is why I recommend doing
healthy keto and intermittent fasting to
fix this right here it's also going to
help improve your digestion to the point
where you're not going to get so much
bloating because bloating in general can
really interfere with your sleep cycles
okay then we have electromagnetic fields
or electromagnetic frequency so like
this stuff right here on the cellphone
the computer all day long around power
cables that can really throw off the
pineal gland and your sleep cycles and
increased cortisol big-time so watch my
video on when I talk about EMF on this
cuz it's quite interesting overtraining
with exercise can do it just with no
recovery I've had people exercise too
much and their pulse rate so high they
can't seem to get it down so the pulse
rate in general keeps you them from
getting into a deep sleep but if you're
not overtraining a good amount of
exercise can help you sleep so it really
all depends on your recovery system but
when you're sleeping you're actually
building up your recovery system so the
key is you know optimizing your workouts
there are certain nutrients that you can
take to actually reduce course all
potassium is a big one make sure that
you have enough potassium because
potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it calms the muscles down
the nerves down and also vitamin b1 is
really good to help reduce cortisol this
one right here you'll feel it within
minutes after taking b1 you'll feel the
sense of
taxation but this is a really important
one right here because high levels of
cortisol deplete your be what they also
to clean your potassium in magnesium too
so magnesium is another one that goes
along with potassium that can help calm
you down in a reduced cortisol
another thing that's really good is
walking like for like a half hour or
maybe in 45 minutes
very good for cortisol very good for the
adrenals it gets you into another
environment and it really will help you
reduce cortisol alright guys those are
the tips to help you reduce cortisol so
you can sleep at night so if you're
enjoying this content go ahead and share
it with someone that could really
benefit from it